klima protest auf unseren straßen so
läuft seit monaten auch hier in berlin
vor allen dingen absolut nervig für
zehntausende die einfach bloß zur arbeit
wollen morgens ja die klima kleber auch
direkt vor mir haben sie sie heute früh
auf die straße geparkte stunde also
obendrauf auf dem weg zur arbeit und ihr
protest wird immer noch immer
lebensgefährlich denn sie kreuzen
neuerdings auch bei der formel 1 auf der
grand prix in silverstone und kurz nach
dem start sind diese klimaaktivisten
dann auf die strecke gerammt ein
wirklicher wahnsinns protest den formel
1 chefs und den fahrern bleibt in diesen
momenten die spucke weg nach dem rennen
gibt es dann von formel 1 star lewis
hamilton ein paar erstaunlich britisch
höflich gesetze für diese wahnsinnigen
protestler lewis hamilton sagt nämlich
dass das ist ein sehr gefährlicher sport
ich unterstütze jeden der protestiert
aber es muss sich ja sein bitte bitte
springt nicht einfach auf unsere
rennstrecke um zu protestieren wir
möchten nicht dass ihr euch schaden
zufügt also das ist wirklich erstaunlich
höflich für diesen wahnsinns protest
einiger autofahrer hier in der
hauptstadt die schlagen bei diesen
klimaaktivisten längst schärfere töne an
habe ich zuletzt heute früh gehört und
das sehr sehr lautstark
[Musik]